I play Sookie Stackhouse she's
telepathic waitress and she falls in
love with a vampire and then things get
very complicated very quickly and people
almost kill her
unlike a regular basis or you know
meteor rock that's gonna do a character
oh yeah I get a new dies doesn't die
yeah I get a lot of I get beaten up a
lot and I play the vampire who basically
kills anybody for crimes against Sookie
we just wrapped your second season we
are now I guess technically on hiatus or
unemployed depending on whether or not
they pick up our show for another season
benefit office every Tuesday ah
in in many sci-fi genre shows or books
you know the genre is a framework to
tell the story in a different way and
using space or whatever it may be
vampires as a metaphor for what there's
a point that you want to get across
which i think is what works in our show
and you've got something funny and sexy
and dark and there's something for
everyone go out occasionally
do we leave the has to really against me
now yes